est ce que pour vous il ya phénomène
macron dans ce pays et gérard larcher je
crois qu'il ya tous les cas une bulle
mais comme les bulles de savon un moment
il faisait 4 parce que monsieur macron
il doit d'abord faire aller mieux
l'économie française
c'est sa première tâche et il est quoi
qu'il en dise l'obligé du président de
la république il n'a pas tiré d'une
élection sa légitimité mais de sa
compétence aux côtés du président de la
république
quand j'entends la ministre je pense à
la médecine de molière vous savez je
vais mieux je vais mieux mais finalement
est-ce que je vais aller mieux
ça fait penser aussi aux cas briller au
général de gaulle quand on parlait
d'europe
je pense qu'il ya un islam tout à fait
compatible avec les valeurs de la
république j'aurais on va parler mais
qui veut celui qui vous a dit moi je
parle aussi de celui qui avec lequel la
république est compatible et puis
assurer qu'ils sont pas dans les valeurs
de la république et la scea la
république tout simplement de s'exprimer
la république l'a fait il ya 110 ans en
1905 mais ce qu'elle a fait preuve de
lâcheté certains élus lomé nous est
clairement ces dernières années mais
nous sommes tous nous avons tous parfois
démissionner nous avons tous parfois
démissionner devant certaines atteintes
notamment l'égalité hommes-femmes et
vous craignez effectivement que des
islamistes prennent le pouvoir local
s'ils sont élus par la voie de la
démocratie dans un certain nombre de
territoires
eh bien il faudra que la république
réaffirme que on ne transige pas avec
les valeurs de la république
ça c'est un message qui dépasse les
clivages gauche droite
et quand j'entends monsieur fillon
parlait de dire qu'il veut casser la
baraque
la baraque en question c'est notre
modèle social moi je vais vous reparler
de l'état de la baraque
faisons l'inventaire plus de 10% de
chômeurs 25% de jeunes au chômage
c'est ça l'état de la baraque vrai mais
si elle va si bien la baraque
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas la casser que
dit monsieur le guen à 13,2 milliards de
dette au 30 juin prochain alors c'est
sûr gardons la baraque
ce qu'on propose c'est vraiment un
changement d'accord le disais tout à
l'heure et en répondant aux questions de
votre confrère je disais tout à l'heure
il faut vraiment changer de logiciel
d'accord il faut retrouver le chemin
vers le plein emploi vers la croissance
nous avons une croissance en berne dans
notre pays et il suffira pas
même si je m'en réjouis de commandes de
sous marins ou de rafale il faut
retrouver ce chemin de la croissance et
la baraque au faut aller en train de
s'effondrer sur la france il faut plutôt
construire une nouvelle maison dans
l'est dans les divers quand il ya
toujours des échanges d'amabilités chez
alain juppé on commence à entendre qu'en
fait le programme de françois fillon
c'est celui d'un outsider c'est à dire
qu'il est tellement radical qu'en fait
ils seraient irréalisables et qu' il ya
des mesures qui sont proposés par
exemple il veut supprimer
vous vous dites si je m'égare 600 mille
fonctionnaires en cinq ans c'est à dire
ne pas embaucher un seul fonctionnaire
en cinq ans et on nous dit à nous
journalistes qu'en fait c'est pas un
programme réaliste c'est pas un
programme de quelqu'un qui veut
gouverner tous les cas si l'on mai 2010
est un projet construit depuis bien
longtemps
et avant même que les sondages ne le
mesure
c'est un projet qui peut encore est à
débattre
moi par exemple je suis sur certains
aspects un peu moins libérale que
françois fillon tout le monde le sait
tout le monde sait que je contribue à
apporter un certain nombre d'éléments d'
équilibre avec d'autres
je vous dit pas si leur congrès ou pas
et c'est pas moi c'est le président de
la république alors est ce que le
président de la république peut faire un
ersatz de réformes constitutionnelles
souvenez le sujet avait été évoqué
est-ce que ça mérite de convoquer le
congrès
votre avis d'amour du monde je ne suis
pas certain que ça le mérite aujourd'hui
puisque la pratique n'est pas en
distorsion moi si ça vient encombrer jeu
le voterait à titre personnel
donc les choses sont claires je le
voterai at il personne que vous rejetez
tout procès d'intention du ministre de
la justice
je ne suis pas pressé mais attention je
vous donne mon vote jeudi que le prof
2010la justice a évolué mais je
considère qu' il appartient au président
de la république de décider ou non s'il
convoque le congrès je considère moi
c'est votre avis je considère que la
réunion du congrès n'est pas opportune
aujourd'hui c'est votre avis personnel
autre cas vous avez donné votre vote les
députés ont voté contre ça veut dire que
là il ya un flou et quand il ya un flou
il ya un autre les députés et les
sénateurs brouillard est floue il ya eu
un vote en 2013 par un groupe ump à
l'époque auquel j'appartenais je ne
change pas mon vote jeudi que la réunion
du conseil ne paraît pas opportune à
quincy le président de la république
mais c'est à lui qu'il appartient de
décider car s'il réunit sous l'eau ou
non le congrès mon vote vous le
connaissez la glace ça c'est clair et
net
qu'est ce que vous répondez à
l'accusation du ministre tandis que la
droite alizés oui caporaliser la justice
et ils veulent des pros corps tout ça
c'est des mots et que ceci amène un peu
ce que veut nicolas sarkozy prononcé des
mots excessifs enfin voyons rappelons
nous qu elle était le projet de madame
taubira
c'était le corporatisme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
puisqu'il s'agissait de donner la
majorité aux magistrats mais la gauche a
beaucoup reproché à nicolas sarkozy
certains la page de marleau du texte
parlons pas nicolas sarkozy
je vous parle du tac il ya eu une
réunion cet après-midi à matignon autour
du terrorisme
il ya certainement eu des vocations
autour de l'état d'urgence est ce que
vous savez quand aura lieu le vote sur
l'extension de l'état d'urgence au sénat
le 10 mai a priori
nous aurons la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence et personnellement je soutiens
cette prorogation du fait de leurs hauts
et leurs bas hall du tour de france mais
l'état d'urgence ne saurait être un état
permanent et en même temps je me
questionne
est ce qu'on est en état d'urgence et
qu'on laisse le démon être pris de force
est occupé est-ce qu'on est en état
d'urgence et qu'on laisse ici ou là je
ne tente pas de manifestations légitimes
syndicales organisées les nuits de
l'écurie debout continuer leur violence
peut pas y avoir deux régime de l'état
d'urgence est à l'urgence est un état
exceptionnel par lequel il nous faut
garantir aussi la préservation des
droits et vous savez que le sénat est
extrêmement attentif non peut pas
réclamer d'un côté de l'état d'urgence
et l'essai de l'autre côté la chienlit
ça veut dire donc que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'agit pas en fonction par
rapport à l'état d'urgence qui est
actuel aller à 100 mètres du sénat sur
vous verrez si c'est l'état d'urgence
c'est le cirque sépare et à ions
certains comme je répète encore nicolas
sarkozy avait parlé de chienlit à
l'époque vous reprendrez seconde
générale ou du général de gaulle vient
de reprendre et vous estimez que
vraiment c'est à l'échelle du pays que
cette chienlit s'est installée amplement
à l'arrêt du car il du pl je prends cet
exemple
oui on est à cent mètres du sénat et
regarder ce qui se passe et ce que c'est
appliquez état d'urgence
donc vous demander des gestes ferme du
mercure intérieur c sont égaux face à
l'état d'urgence
à travers ce genre de pression des
marchés parlons at à dire ces
manifestations comme celle de mis debout
par hasard il faudrait l'évaluer inter
ne peut pas continuer à tolérer
derrière chaque lui debout y ait des
violences et vais pas aussi quand même
cette impression qu'on ne sait pas
sortir de cet état d'urgence aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation
exceptionnelle la menace est très élevé
et dans la situation dans laquelle je
suis je sais que c'est élevé que c'est
pas des propos qui seraient les propos
circonstanciel et face à cette menace
élevée
il n'empêche qu'il va falloir un moment
sortir de l'état d'urgence organiser le
pays
pour faire face de manière permanente au
risque et en même temps retrouvé l'état
de droit dans sa plénitude
parce que l'état d'urgence suspens une
partie quand même des libertés comment
fait-on pour sortir de cet état
d'urgence est une question
d'organisation et c'est ce que conduit
actuellement le ministre de l'intérieur
il nous tient informés
d'ailleurs ce que fait le premier
ministe c'était jean claude gaudin qui
cet après midi me représenter à cette
réunion
moi même je suis avec beaucoup
d'attention et je recevrai dans 48
heures d'ailleurs et membre éminent
charge des suivis par les deux sens
cette réunion où les par dire plus non
plus et moi l'important ce d'efficacité
de la sécurité vous évoquez la sortie de
l'état d'urgence pourtant la menace
terroriste elle est toujours la même
elle n'a pas changé mais vous ne pouvez
pas rester en permanence en état
d'urgence il faut qu'à un moment le pays
s'organisent pour s'installer face à une
zone de risque qui est différente
d'accord cela ne vous donne pas des
regrets quand on vois l'échec de la
réforme constitutionnelle où vous devez
inscrire l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution
ça aurait pu être une façon aussi de
sortir dignement de cet état d'urgence
et qu'il y ait un cadre non il ya un
cadre des lois de 55 donc le cadre il
existe fallait-il constitutionnaliser la
réponse le sénat l'a donné clairement le
gouvernement s'est pris les pieds dans
la sphère de la déchéance de crédit
c'est ce qu'il vous a retiré aujourd'hui
assumer son incapacité d'avoir pu
conduire avec sa majorité
les engagements du président de la
république à versailles chacun se
renvoie la balle est ce qu'il vous en
thierry goor exécutif aujourd'hui envoyé
c'est le président de la république oui
bon bon et vous ont renvoyé la balle à
manuel valls et vous dit vous jouez à
y a que ça qui vous intéresse nous pas
du tout j'ai simplement dit que le sénat
avait ligne rouge qui aurait pas
d'apatridie allons quand même pas
scandale de dire à un homme de gauche
qui depuis les valeurs de gauche qui
depuis 1922 se bat contre la patrie 10
de leur rappeler quand même et que c'est
un combat qui mérite quelques quelques
respect alors l'accusation effectivement
un homme qu'elle est venu de la gauche
on vous a accusé de jouer en fête 2010
est l'alternance
et vous personnellement c'est le
sénateur ps luc carvounas qui vous
accuse de manquer d'impartialité gérard
larcher lors des questions d'actualité
on l'écouté vous allez pouvoir lui
répondre d'ailleurs gérard larcher hier
était extrêmement virulent a coupé le
micro de tout le monde donc c'est pas
non plus ma conception de l'animation de
l'hémicycle gérard larcher coup plus
vite le micro quand il s'agit d'un
orateurs de gauche que de droite et il
est beaucoup plus cool sur le timing et
le chrono quand il s'agit d'un orateurs
de droite que de gauche
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
votre réponse totalement faux j'ai fait
un petit statistiques que j'ai rapporté
il ya trois semaines
conférence des présidents la différence
entre socialistes et républicains
ces 52 centièmes de seconde
pendant trois mois vous rendez compte
monsieur carvounas et sensible c'est un
sprinteur et même les communistes ont
dépassé de 8 secondes
16 les écologistes de 7 secondes pour
vous rendez compte
monsieur carvounas il faut qu'il
reprenne son chronomètre djia a lâché
pour rester un petit peu société sur
d'actualité dabo sur les réformes qui
ont été amenés au sénat il ya eu ce
droit de réplique qui est arrivé est ce
que ça a changé fondamentalement la
donne des questions d'actualité au sénat
je pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est que
chaque semaine nous nous retrouvons pour
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et que donc il commence
quelque part à y avoir un rendez vous
avec une partie du pays autour des
questions d'actualité au sénat que ce
soit le mardi
et la semaine suivante le jeudi c'est
aussi je crois le sentiment que le sénat
ait au travail et on le voit dans
l'application tout simplement des règles
de fonctionnement qui sont maintenant
rentrer dans tous les esprits avec une
valorisation du travail du du sénat je
sors dans le pays mais et c'est partager
et d'ailleurs nous voyons bien sont
d'ailleurs ces bénéficiaires public
sénat et nous avons des audiences qui ki
moon
nous avons plus de 320 mail abonnée à
twitter
notre cité est incroyablement fréquenté
tout ceci nous amène dans une meilleure
rencontre avec le pays et je dois dire
que les sénateurs majorité comme
opposition ont cette rencontre plus
forte me semble-t-il avec le pays c'est
en tous les cas ce que je ressens que je
ressent très fortement y compris par
rapport à la masse des changes que je
peux avoir avec les nos compatriotes
vous ce président il ya deux cas de
déclaration mensongère devant des
commissions du sénat
ce sont deux cas bien distincts on va
bien faire la distinction celui de
michel aubier qui est un célèbre
pneumologue au sujet de l'impact du
désastre la santé celui de frédéric
oudéa ancien président de cas à l'époque
de la société générale pour une affaire
de paradis fiscaux le sénat at il était
bafouée à tous les cas que la procédure
soit engagée
c'est légitime c'est légitime parce que
venir devant une commission d'enquêté et
s'exprimer sous serment c'est quelque
chose de le sérieux c'est même quelque
chose de symbolique et que donc quand on
aime les enfants disant 'tiens je ne
qualifie pas la faute nous verrons une
fois les procédures
la procédure se déroule en bureau du
sénat va donc examiner
à la suite d'une nouvelle audition qu'a
fait l'ancien président monsieur husson
l'ancien rapporteur la magie du
professeur biais claude bérit-debat
rapportera devant le bureau
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent examiner peu
risqué mais surprise c'est parce qu'il
peut risquer c'est plus simplement que
bureau décide ou non de transmettre par
la république avant vos procureur et
concernant le président de la société
génère alors on est sur un sujet assez
comparable qui a été actée je le
rappelle les rives mans par les
révélations de panama peppers sur les
paradis fiscaux y sommes tous les
gouvernants mais la commission des
finances je lui rappelais cet après-midi
appelé cet après midi la commission des
finances est dans son rôle quand elle
procède à un contrôle et qu'elle va
procéder à un contrôle
en même temps l'ancien président de la
commission denquête monsieur dominati a
souhaité entendre monsieur oudéa et
ensuite ils ont la capacité de saisir le
bureau qui examinera suivant la même
procédure
au mois de mai et quelles sont les
conséquences pour monsieur oudéa lors le
communiste alain bocquet lui demande la
saisie du bureau immédiatement dès la
saisie avec des sanctions peut-être
alors on va l'écouter alain vautier
répondu j'espère que vous entendrez
l'accompagnement j'ai appris par la
bouche de monsieur larcher le président
du sénat que monsieur oudéa serait
auditionné le 11 mai prochain ce qui est
une bonne chose maintenant créons les
conditions pour que cette audition
débouche sur la vérité parce que moi
j'ai simplement mis en regard les
déclarations de monsieur des apps faites
sous serment le 17 avril 2012 et les
révélations faites par l'epa damas
papers et à hiatus entre les deux à
l'évidence sera-t-il sous serment parce
que c'est important ça qu'il a menti
sous serment il aurait menti sous
serment
sera-t-il alors il sera pas sous serment
à mi-saison qui vont bien au delà de
l'émission d' enquête mais la présidente
de la commission et je ne doute pas
monsieur nominative monsieur locales
feront part de leurs sentiments et je
lui soumettrai ensuite pour instruction
au bureau dans fait une procédure
d'ailleurs monsieur bloqué vient de
reconnaître qu'il fallait pas à faire
dans l'immédiat
valls donné les délais nécessaires savez
on est sur des matières qui nécessite à
la fois la vérité la
édité et on n'est pas sous la pulsion
par contre il est de mon devoir de faire
que devant une commission d enquête du
sénat
quand on parle sous serment
on dise la vérité et rien que la vérité
quand vous l'avez vécu tout cela à titre
peut-être personnel vous qui habitez par
le sénat mais je pense que c'est le
sénat qui joue parfaitement son rôle
vous voyez on ne considère pas que les
affaires passe comme ça que ce soit sur
la sphère de la santé publique ou la
faire de l'éthique financière
le sénat est dans son rôle et dans sa
fonction de contrôle
et voilà je dis toujours que le sénat a
une responsabilité particulière dans le
contrôle et vous voyez que le contrôle
nous l'appliquer alors qu'avez vous à
dire aux accusations d'une association
qui s'appelle démocratie directe qui
accuse députés et sénateurs et même vous
même d'avoir touché ce qu'on pourrait
appeler dès des suppléments de
rémunération d'indemnités
supplémentaires
d'abord je dis attention hein attention
tout ça relève
ça devrait être ma conclusion d'un anti
parlementarisme qu'on cultive et je dis
aussi attention journalistes je le dis
avec respect mais de répondre ce genre
de choses sans avoir vérifié au
préalable d'ailleurs je n'ai reçu que
deux jours après la lettre de monsieur
lebreton méthode résidence est associé
et ensuite j'ai pu lui répondre une base
légale 1947 une base légale parce que
comme générale de la sécurité code de la
sécurité sociale
cg contrôle de la cour des comptes et
comparaison avec d'autres parlements je
pense à l'allemagne ou le royaume uni
il y aura des sens des choses qu parra
j'ai fait la réponse à monsieur lebreton
j'ai vu qu'il se sent prêt c'est moins
d'être sur les ondes pour expliquer la
réponse que je lui avais c'est monsieur
bartolone
je crois qu'il faut simplement faire
attention attention à
l'anti-parlementarisme dans ces temps de
crise c'est facile mais c'est dangereux
pour la télé quand les candidats de
droite tous demandent moins de
parlementaires et aux participants on
parle de réformes
et je ne dis pas que la procédure
parlementaire ne doivent pas être
réformé
j'ai moi-même dans la réforme du sénat
est proposé et ça fait partie d'ailleurs
des propositions que je viens d'envoyer
au président de groupe à la suite du
travail de monsieur karoutchi d'alain
richard est ce qu'on me donne pas un
temps de commissions et un temps de
séance un peu différent